allora amici oggi sono quelli buon jean
e siamo limitato perché volevamo tattoo
artist frutto per fare video è
semplicemente perché non volevo che tu
assistessi a questa cosa incredibile che
stiamo per andare a giocare io questo è
un gioco hanno già fatto due volte non
12 il rap è un replay però la prima tela
fatto sul mio primissimo canale quello
che in cui non parlino di cui il primo
prix poi l'ho fatto su questo canale ma
era proprio lì quindi quando ero di cui
non parliamo neanche di quelli adesso
vorrei fare dice vorrei fare in modo
decoroso questo video e trattare
d'artifice of lobbying che sarebbe il
primo dei due giochi di colori da fatti
quindi molto molto molto fino allora
amico mio
senti sì mi ricordo che tutte e due le
volte che l'ho giocato la seconda volta
ho capito meno della prima però è
fantastico quindi è un viaggio goditelo
ok ok il colle n music hall qualcosa da
verburg ma che cosa se non ci sarà una
spia per gioco di spie prima mi parla
anche io che sono la spia sacco i fuochi
e film di spie di spie anni però è un
gioco un po particolare sulle perché la
vita ciao anita quest'anno la ricordano
una sera
era uno dei flashback cose tipo di
facebook su lei chi era tv lo sa è una
che prepara le torte una cecchina
un'infiltrata un sacco di roba capisco
cosa sta facendo fuori della scorsa
giornata era lui
finora il migliore ok è legato al caso
sentiti sulle o che ti fanno vedere
anche le occhi come fossero di respiro
che peccato
e stato bellissimo ci avevo creduto e
che mi piace altro a questa descrizione
della faccenda
avevo ci sono cannes o perché dai sun
notare le 9 quindi questa nascondiglio
segreto dietro al bar di dei vecchi
detto knox
vai la morte e bussa anita sono sono
organizzati bene questi film sono in cui
tantissimi tratta solo di solito darti
flames of loving cosa è successo non so
anita ci sta sparando ci sta minacciando
ma io sono posso muovermi ciao e mi
ricordo la battuta una roba tipo che era
quando una donna ha un'arma e le
mestruazioni meglio di levarsi dai
comuni era il 2013 quindi non ero di
sicuro nelson mandela
buongiorno di sopra il best man e ferito
è esatto morinho io lo so ma io lo posso
trascinare prenderlo
ma cosa perché mi punta la pistola
addosso l'essere perché io parli una
cosa lascia la porta guardia proprio dio
è una è un aeroporto
ma cos'è è ultimamente la metro a metro
a nome del genere non lo spazioporto è
uno spazioporto esistono gli spazio
forte termine che esiste e si beh
esistere esiste mai un aeroporto
comunque è morto la panne jolas cray
album valia lo slow beatles di malo solo
dito sui avere dovreste una richiesta
tizia aiuto alla mostra qualcosa a ci
metto lui sopra che lo trascino vai vai
vai
no dunque non aeroporto che era rapporto
hite è un po è un po strano con
aeroporto visto che nello spazio però
era un sogno
sembrerebbe che siamo in un letto quindi
se un letto tanto definito nitra
buonasera piacciono i mandarini
ecco già questa casa aveva dovresti
spiegare perché dovresti buttare gocce
di mandarino fuori dalla finestra e
chiudiamola un cestino
caro ma io posso il bello che non ci
sono i confini della stanza che posso
letteralmente suicidarmi
volendo se credo di sì e no no c'è il
respons
a posso buttare anch'io e mandarini giu
capitolo sarà un modo di passare la
serata che ti devo dire
max bruch in mandarino prima o poi
sbocciare anche lei si spera trovare
sbucciare non so posso dirle queste cose
dirlo a sbucciare non penso ma non
saltarle in testa mia e io rimorchio
così come sul come sbucciato partendo
dai vestiti di certo non dalla luca non
è il suo compleanno ha chiaramente detto
buon compleanno seguì ci si immagina era
più eloquente igd ea bodies di exodus
assolutamente e ci sono porte non mi fa
gli auguri tu no è tipo di legami si
faccia i fatti suoi
ma nessuno a scale di sopra di sotto beh
io sono uno appena tirato una pizza
mitch è un micio tristi ma tanto triste
sì sono caduto dalle scale non può campi
via no il gatto innamorato bellissimo
pranzo le vediamo
buonasera signor esatto quanti amici ma
che ce l'abbiamo paradisi non stava
benissimo però la roma censis
siccome non detto che premette dobbiamo
andare assolutamente sul tesi e immagino
un sacco nel segnale polizia va bene a
capodanno cinese
nasce una festa sul tetto buono se altro
che anita si compenetra chiamo eve
parlava di come vuole compenetrare
questa che ti avvicini abbastanza e
jerry compenetrate esatto in realtà in
realtà è sono fissata con questa fare
qua a me piace segnati nelle cose per
rimorchiare intermedi si divertono un
sacco senza musica e rigorosa ma è un
matrimonio a il matrimonio esatto li
invita e no e noi siamo ci sta
divertendo tutti loro beh più o meno
andato ma perché i matrimoni non ci si
diverta erano fai finta sono convegno
quanto scazzati di ballare questi gli
accoppiati intanto inoltre eccoci qua
alla fine nella festa mia la festa di
matrimonio e avete potuto noto sta a voi
per lo speriamo discorso discorso
non solo proprio sono curioso di vedere
che discorso può mai essere ecco è una
promessa che non tutti farlo io chapeau
tanto di cartello ma facendo sta
ballando cosa che se ami sa che qua
finisce lisce può essere che il momento
che con anita si vada in secondo me no
io non mi alzerei neanche più dal tavolo
dopo questa voglia e questo per chi sa
io devo andare ubriaco di giu
sì va bene anita arrivo prima io ecco la
vedi te l'ho detto la manita il biscotto
è a è la realtà è questa
cioè nel senso poi la vita ti ritorna
siamo tornati fa con lui fa lui in mezzo
morto e anita che mi sputa la pistola
sono cammino perché ti sei sono solo è
bancato tutto ok siamo tornati in lei è
a una narrazione un po la natura momento
esatto profilo lorenzo a traverso devo
ti fossi datare la ristorazione il mio
meglio il mio franchisor va avanti ha
ricercato wiston borges lui e si è lui
winston corri no vabbè accostare
italiani si per fuggire è fantastica
come amici morenti vola con la q da
terre dimenticate il tuo passato
no grazie per aver voluto con noi giorno
fa finisce in mano te lo dico lattice
cioè una boss battle chiara ecco infatti
che se è successo
la polizia la polizia attività polizia
spara anche attraverso questi kosice non
è che sono guai si è evoluta a lui sta
sparando 8 chiaro ma nessuno dei rumori
di oche
ecco perché sono e sono loro la polizia
d'oro cagano la polizia veli
cioè nomi non so povero cornicione
bravissimo non si sa come altro
definirlo abbastanza russa no c'è la
polizia in rosa
come abbiamo come abbiamo fatto a salire
su una macchina come non farti domande
di cui non necessariamente subire la
risata che presi no ai tagli o france
come possibile oddio come siamo sul
cambio sono su una moto ma se quelle
unità questa è unita ok ma guarda tu
stai andando almeno nemmeno scelta
guarda no tav ha ricordato sta roba mio
zio fine ma vabbè io non so cosa dire
non so come descrivere tutto questo è un
piccolo cortometraggio interattivo sì
però c'è una vecchia casa la macchina
finale maria ma spiega miceti prego per
the flight blogging driver riven
spiegami questo è un museo adesso si è
un museo cui crediti ma forse non è
finito
ecco forse sì d'artifice flogging
complimenti regala forse allora se
dobbiamo cercare un senso tutto ciò
potrebbe essere che eri una spia è fatto
un colpo con anita e cosa chiaro però
tipo non è andata bene se e allora tu ti
sei reinventato artista è deciso di
raccontare la tua storia è questa daniel
per lui non è proprio daniel bernoulli
la faccia di daniel bernoulli le robe
scientifiche che non sai cosa c'entrino
adesso quindi 13 mi sono reinventato
artista potrei potrebbe essere così a ti
spiega come funzionali aerei
non è finito vediamo adesso che adesso
grazie mille cioè non so cos'altro dire
no grazie a loro grazie a loro e sotto
anzi grazie ad anita che guida che seguì
da voyeur è un caso quindi è finito
proprio c'è sempre mais che a lei si
chiude prof
ecco il gioco che vedi lì sotto avrebbe
più senso secondo me però va bene così
ecco questo gioco è un po come la vita
di un mandarino cioè sbucciato pian
piano ho poi c'è il
il cielo non eliminarle o un frutto
frutto è il frutto si può dividere in
tanti spicchi e ognuno di quegli spicchi
comunque nel momento in cui lo strappi
provoca un po di dolore ma soltanto
tramite il dolore possiamo crescere
passare al prossimo mandarino siate al
vostro spicchio siate la mia buccia
[Musica]